noah
i feel like maybe you should wikipedia
me
[Laughter]
it was my educated guess
all right so oh my god dude oh that
means i'm sorry katy perry was totally
triggered during monday's episode of
american idol after contestant noah
thompson performed a song by her ex john
mayer
[Music]
i'm gonna let the comments roll
let us get you up to speed the top 11
contestants had to sing one of three
songs selected by the three judges luke
bryan lionel richie and katie but here's
the catch they didn't know which judge
selected which song and the hilariously
awkward moment went down after noah
performed john's 2009 track heartbreak
warfare a song he assumed was chosen for
him by katie honestly i don't know i
picked katie that was my guess
so you sticking with it yes
i have to now
katie is that true noah
i feel like maybe you should wikipedia
me
[Applause]
uh yeah big no noah i want to ask about
this noah and his inability to wikipedia
oh god bless him in fact if he had
wikipedia at katie he would know the 37
year old singer and the grammy winner
had a very on and off relationship from
2012 to 2015
it was my educated guess
all right so oh my god dude oh that
means i'm sorry these two judges staying
the rest of the night
uh who
wait wait she's not up here hey we'll
explain later no
so if it wasn't katie who picked that
john mayer song who was it luke or
lionel
who was it
come on guys who was it
and katie who has been with orlando
bloom since 2016 she selected a song by
another john john denver
i figured he picked the john denver he's
only 20 years old and he's got his own
life and his own baby and his baby mama
you know he busy he don't need to know
my whole history
and he sounded great and i'm just glad
that he is still continuing to challenge
himself katie had a good laugh with e.t
after the whole thing went down and
opened up about her tight bond with the
contestants i love them and i'm glad i i
make them feel safe and seen but i am
very you know i i'm a little bit of a
stage mom and even more so on this
competition so i'm pushing these kids to
you know show a card they've never
uh you know given or challenged
themselves well safe to say noah's
newest challenge learning to use
wikipedia
noah
i feel like maybe you should wikipedia
me
[Music]